okay welcome back everyone
so um we're ready for our next speaker
um damien andrew tamburi is a
very interesting speaker he's based in
italy right now
he's an associate professor at tui
here in eindhoven and also at euron's
euronymous academy of data science
his interest and focus is on complex
software
and data architectures and he's here
today to talk about the
radon framework which is an eu funded
project
to work on
[Music]
basically open source frameworks for
creating microservice applications
on top of uh to leverage uh serverless
computing
so uh very exciting uh a new topic i
think there's going to be a lot of
developments in service computing
so very eager to uh hear his thoughts
now
uh damien has uh requested
to show a pre-recorded video
uh this is because of uh some potential
instability issues in the connection
so we will stream the video currently
um however he is online right now so he
is going to
watch the discord channel on the talk
closely
for any of the questions that you may
have and also
he will be available for any sort of
networking questions regarding maybe
job opportunities at toue or interest of
if you're maybe interested in going to
study there or doing a phd
so please reach out to him with any of
these kinds of questions um
as well so uh enough talking let's
get started with the um with the video
so it looks like uh the recording is
started
uh so hello everyone unfortunately you
are not seeing my face but i'm showing
it here now
on purpose uh because as it turns out i
have a nice face
but on the other hand uh you won't see
me with a tie
and neck noose as often as you
might think in the sense that i'm very
much a nerd so i will welcome
your questions after your present after
uh this presentation
so what is the presentation about
i want to tell you a little bit about
what you
as a data scientist can do in the
context of using serverless
machine learning operations and what i
have been doing
in the scope of a european project
called radon
which has in fact at the core
uh this idea of proposing an endeavor to
uh to structure serverless computing in
the scope of machine learning pipelines
and without further ado let me just say
a few words about myself my name is
damian andrew
tambury i'm an associate professor at
eindhoven university of technology
but i dwell mostly and spend most of my
time
at yachts the euronymous academy of data
science
and i'm going to tell you a little bit
more about that
now uh for the nerds of you out there
like me uh men and women after my own
heart
you'll find a nice qr code in the bottom
right and an email so reach out to me
or my personal website or professional
website
in case anything is not clear or
anything uh
might inspire your curiosity beyond
what we can deal with uh next week
because go figure i'm registering and
recording this on october 2nd
all right so let's go through a bit of a
road map for today
uh first of all i'm going to tell you a
little bit about uh
yachts and the jade lab of which i'm
the executive head and then i want to
delve deeper into what is
this mlaps paradigm for those of you who
are not familiar with it
but also what is serverless what is
function as a service
and then i'm going to delve deeper into
what we propose and how we propose
to address these frameworks
and these technology in the scope of the
radon machine learning operations
approach
so reflecting this very rich and dense
road map
let me say a few words about the
aeronautics academy of data science
well first of all let me just say that
it is
an initiative joint initiative in fact
from the eindhoven university of
technology where i dwell from
uh and uh tilburg university
uh which is as some of you might know a
peculiarly catholic and somewhat
old-fashioned university
dealing most especially in human and
humane
and societal and social aspects not only
of computing but also
of society in general so
yachts emerged as a combination of the
social sociotechnical expertise
uh at uvt and the more technical more
hardcore
uh super uh theoretical
and practical as well expertise at
eindhoven university of technology
there's been growth on every front so
you see some of the figures here
in this in this slide right here
we have about 300 students with a growth
of the number of about 250 percent
yearly although
covid has in fact taken a lot of
uh of that away so i want to say that
number uh is down to
let's say more or less 100 percent uh
growth uh in the sense that every
pre-master period normally gets about 50
to 70 students
uh for uh for the yearly programs of
course the total amount that you see
in the 289 figure that reflects the
total amount of students
which is enrolled between the master's
degree the pdn programs
and the phd program um so
so so numbers are in fact thriving uh
and our activities have been going on
since
uh 2016. as you can see queen maximum
here
herself she came and opened up the
initiative
uh uh since uh about four years now in
fact
um now what is uh
the jade lab in the context of this now
jade stands for euronymous academy data
and engineering lab so
at jade we address all aspects
of software and data engineering
research
software defined infrastructures and
software defined everything
in fact as well as applied machine
learning research
applied machine learning operations so
what is known as
data ops what
what is known as mlops
is a part of the the recent trend of
of data ops and what it comes from it
essentially we are talking about
deploying continuously refining and
improving
machine learning pipelines as they are
being evolved
with direct feedback from either
customers themselves or
telemetry from runtime now all of these
topics
of course we are trying to apply in very
specific
very uh impactful uh
problems uh in areas or domains
uh i'm reporting the two major ones
which we are addressing so
smart industry and crime and society
sustainable societies at that
and i will show you a couple examples
more specifically in the
[Music]
data and smart industry uh contexts
uh which specifically in fact reflects
uh
the project that i'm going to show you
in a bunch of slides
so uh let me give you just again let me
give you just an example of the projects
that we are taking care of
uh so eu age 2020 radon and satellite
are two
of the seven currently active research
uh projects uh uh funded from uh from
the european by the european union
in the horizon 2020 framework program
and both projects in fact reflect
using large-scale cloud applications
either in the scope of serverless
computing
for the radon project or in the scope of
high performance computing
for the sodalite project to carry out
predictive maintenance and application
defect and failure proactive
analytics in the scope of
large-scale cloud applications so
this is just one example of the projects
that we are conducting if you are
interested in knowing more
please reach out to me throw me a shout
out send me an email
twitter whatever you can think of i'm
all open and all
out there ready to welcome whatever you
might have
to ask so in the scope of
these two specific projects i chose to
focus
on radon because it seems like it is
much closer to
the endeavors and domain that pi data
is in fact targeted at so i want to
specifically stress
what we are doing in that direction so
what is ranon where does it come from
well radon is a software technologies uh
a research and innovation action in the
parlance of
h2020 project proposals it is a 30-month
project
with a value proposition which ranges
from
providing a devops framework that helps
the adoption of serverless and function
as a service
technologies while avoiding the
the most inhumane project a problem of
vendor lock-in now in that respect
let me just give you a few primers on
what devops is for those of you who are
neophytes
in that respect and also to serverless
and fast at a later stage
so first off devops some of you
might know this already so devops is is
really a
is a is a menu is a la carte uh
menu it's a set of practices that
essentially accelerate
the continuous release and re-release a
software components of any kind which
means
including ai software now
typically these two dev and ops
used to be two sides of the same coin
and in principle you would have dev
teams
later decommissioning the work to ops
teams when developer
developers themselves would have
finished
their you know prototypical and
experimentation and validation work on
their own prototypes
and then ops people would put those
prototypes into operations
with the hope that those prototypes
would perform well with the end
customers
but recently a trend has been emerging
in which
a series of practices have been trying
to combine these two silos
uh not only from an organizational
perspective so for example it is
very common nowadays to find what are
known as
devops teams but also from a technical
perspective with all series of practices
to accelerate
the creation the verification the
packaging the releasing
but also the configuration the
integration the deployment
of whatever software components you
might think of
now if you draw this world into
uh into the world of
big data then you have
large-scale data intermixed with devops
software components
so you can think of all sorts of
software components that reflect
big data and data intensive computing uh
just to give you a cue
a couple of examples here you find nosql
databases as opposed to
all sorts of compute platforms like
spark storm flink
kafka whatever hadoop or
whatever the hell you can think of
all of these obviously have specific
challenges but also specific needs and
actors
involved and that's why the trend
of devops being dedicated to specific
big data and data intensive compute
applications has been known or has been
coined as data ops so the
operations the development and
operations around
data intensive computing now again
if you can textualize that even further
specifically designing it for example in
the scope
of predictive proactive preventive
analytics
which harness machine and deep learning
or ai software in general
then you would have you would have
things like
lambda architecture dedicated to
specific machine learning jobs
so a lambda architecture is as
some of you know already a typical
architecture pattern for
big data and data intensive compute
applications but it can be
made to function in the scope of
machine learning operations but from a
more classical standpoint
machine learning operations really
reflect what you are doing day to day
in your data scientific endeavor in
which you have any source of data
sources
uh uh any set of data sources and
a number of libraries and middleware
like pytorch thiano
keras or tensorflow or whatever or any
combination thereof
uh so so this uh has been known to
to to emerge as ml ops
because again you have different
concerns different uh
stakeholders different issues and
challenges
and also technical solutions
which reflect anything between the
continuity of your deployed model
or the automated retraining or active
learning
of your own model as well
now comes serverless computing what is
this serverless computing thing
how does it reflect ml ops where is it
coming from
where is it going well for those of you
who are geeks
and nerds like me you might know
this evolution that i'm showing you here
now
indeed you have things like
originally you had things like
applications being designed for specific
bare metal uh configurations and then
on top of that you had virtualization
you had hypervisoring so you had
uh cloud infrastructures that you could
use to deploy and continuously operate
your applications
but then you came to containers and how
containers changed the world
is that they effectively inserted
onto the technological market the
ability
uh to quickly scale up or down uh
specific applications with their own
technical space into containerized into
packaged formats that would allow them
uh to to to be relocated uh very
very easily this architecture pattern
was known to be
micro services and that's why
this neatly red
shaded box around containers bears the
mark of
micro services there's all sorts of
containerized
micro service trends and technologies
thereof
you can think of i don't know kubernetes
or docker or whatever is your favorite
there's so many out there but at the
same time
containers themselves and microservices
for that matter
did not really specify the level of
granularity
to which your own whatever general
purpose
application was supposed to be designed
and operated
and at which level of abstraction that
decomposition should have been made
that's where
functions come in and where serverless
computing
really realizes its promise because
functions themselves
are essentially fine-grained units of
computation
which are hosted in the cloud and fully
managed by the provider
it doesn't mean that there is no server
serverless by itself
means that you are not
supposed to manage anything from the
server side
the server is a transparent device
to you the functional programmer and
this
also means that you have all sorts of
cost savings
that your workloads are event driven
and also that you are
paying for compute cycles you are
paying for whatever function runtime you
actually realize you are not
paying for the deployment of a specific
work unit or a specific microservice so
even though there is in fact
architecturally a strong synergy with
microservices
there is no restriction from a
deployment perspective your function
is only deployed insofar as
it is consuming computational resources
and this provides for example in the
scope of
amazon web services architecture this
provides for
all sorts of benefits
from a development perspective for
example you would run code without
servers because you can use all sorts of
existing libraries you can make your own
rotating around specific technologies
but also
while you upload your own functions and
configure
the triggers in an event-driven fashion
for those functions
you forget about
managing whatever deployment details and
whatever
serverless specific uh
continuous infrastructure management
considerations you might
you might think of so let me give you an
example of
these sort of these sort of
pipelines or these sort of
functional approaches
imagine the classical extract transform
load data pipeline you have all sorts of
arrivals of raw data
in the data store and you have all sorts
of triggers
being triggered by specific data events
so for example specific types of data
are being input or
specific cues are being filled out
in the scope of queuing management so
you have all sorts of streaming data
coming in
what you as an etl engineer want to do
is
take that data in understand what that
data is about and
process it in such a way that you come
up with
enhanced data now what you see
also in this domain is a
very much transient very much
event driven pipeline which features all
sorts of analysis all sorts of
annotation all sorts of enhancements
being done
uh in uh in the the data pipeline
so how about you actually turn whatever
intelligence
is taking care of the analysis those
annotations those enhancements
and you realize that intelligence with a
series of serverless functions
that are triggered like that
by events in the scope of the
architecture
but also are rigged to consume the least
amount of resources possible what is the
outcome of that well the outcome is
quite obvious
you have improved data integration for
downstream
consumers but also at the lowest
expense possible um
so again imagine implementing this etl
data pipeline
featuring all sorts of fine-grained
event management all sorts of continuous
and unpredictable load management
and accommodating all sorts of
continuous changes
in your machine learning pipeline
because keep in mind you can manage
a serverless function just like you
would any micro
service in which case you can do all
sorts of things like
more advanced a b testing
and if you don't know what a b testing
is just go and google it it's
actually quite fun as a deployment
testing strategy
but again there's all sorts of benefits
to it
what do you need to make this promise
a real thing and this is where
radon comes in the conjecture that we
have at the basis
of the run on research and innovation
action is that
you definitely need an integrated ide
so an integrated development environment
with all sorts of full stack end-to-end
devops support
but also you might need platform
agnostic
application and machine learning
modeling why platform agnostic because
let's face it you need tensorflow as
much as you need keras as much as you
need all sorts of other libraries which
are
out there so you cannot
endure the luxury of a vendor lock-in
if you are content with hadoop mapreduce
which is available on azure
then go for it maybe you are maybe
you're not
i don't know but if you are going for a
complex
application which features the exact
same characteristics as i've shown you
a couple of slides back then you might
desperately be needing
platform agnosticism because you cannot
endure the luxury
of going back and forth now in the scope
of
those application and ml modeling
you might also want to ensure quality of
your applications and that is
exactly where the flexibility
needs to come in because at the one hand
you have your cost effectiveness but at
the other hand you want to maintain
specific qualities like also security
or a privacy or even simply maintenance
ability and that's especially where
radon comes in
we have in fact realized an integrated
development environment
which is by the way web-based and
container
oriented so eclipse che is a new
spin-off of
the well-known eclipse modeling
and software development environment
which integrates all sorts of
operations view as well
now in that respect we are obviously
supporting
a devops life cycle and let me show you
what kind
of tools and toys we have been
developing for you
uh in the scope of the same challenges
and issues that we have that we have
been discussing
uh in this slide right here um so in
terms of quality assurance or
flexibility
and there you have it so we are
providing you with uh
graphical modeling so you can assemble
your
infrastructure your serverless compute
application
in a plug-and-play fashion in a
drag-and-drop fashion we have provided
you
with a series of
constructs that allow you to
to put together this application i will
show you a bit more of that in a second
but also we want you to reason on how to
decompose your application
whether on uh on the basis
of serverless computing but also for
example on more
fine grain on more sorry more
coarse-grained
micro services also we want you to run
defect prediction on your pipeline
because
the more you grow your application the
more your infrastructure code is going
to become bigger and bigger and bigger
which means you are making yourself
prone to instill defects inside your
software code and at that same level we
want you
to to conduct software verification and
validation
uh so testing and verification on top of
your own
uh solutions lastly
uh from a platform agnosticism
perspective
we want to do your reasoning using a
technology which is
by design platform agnostic
and that is also why we are providing
you with a template library so a series
of constructs
for deployment of whatever you can think
of whatever
application component you can think of
but using a
standard for infrastructure code which
is
not specific to avs which is not
specific to ansible which is not
specific
to terraform which is not specific to to
kubernetes which is not specific to
any one technology and that is
my friends uh the oasis
tosca tosca stands for topology
orchestration
uh uh uh uh specification for cloud
application
uh applications and it is in fact a de
facto
standard for uh platform agnostic
infrastructure code
and that rests me from showing you
the integrated development environment
with end to end
devops support uh which also by the way
includes all sorts of uh continuous
integration conditions deployment
facilities
as well as all sorts of reusable
functions that you might want to
reuse and assemble and i will show an
example in a second
but also lastly it includes monitoring
facilities based on prometheus
which itself is an open source solution
which is customized
to support the radon id and the idea is
that you want to
deploy your application even in a quick
and dirty manner
but also you want to observe this
application
in action and learn from that
application
in such a way that you can in fact
improve it
over time and with telemetry from
the actual the actual usage
so let me show you a bunch of these
tools in action because they are
in fact integrated into the radon ide
let's start from the graphical modeling
this is just a snippet of the graphical
modeling environment
itself as you can see you have a number
of components and on the left hand side
you have a pane
which contains all sorts of constructs
that you can drag and drop and assemble
now the graphical modeling tool also
allows you to
produce tosca based deployable
definitions for whatever you assemble
on the left hand side now i'm leaving
links
and i will show you also links during my
q a session
at pi data to show you how you can reach
these tools how you can play around with
them
for your own large scale serverless
based data pipelines
so go nuts with them and by the way i
only have time to show you a couple of
tools so for example given that you guys
are
machine and girls are machine learning
freaks
just like i am i want to show you the
machine learning intelligence and
predictive maintenance
features inside the write-on approach
featuring for example the defa
prediction
which itself essentially is
rigged to analyze whatever
infrastructure blueprints you come up
with
after you have used the graphical
modeling tool
essentially we have been defining a
number of infrastructure specific
metrics that you can use to analyze the
the well-being the welfare the
healthiness
of these infrastructure blueprints and
as a matter of fact we have
a serverless pipeline to support this
endeavor
as well this is just a series of
details from an architectural
perspective
so if you have questions about this i'm
i don't want to delve too deep
into the details here uh uh just
make a note of what is happening here
and
maybe if you have questions during our q
a sessions
um please do tell
but last but not least i want to ensure
you that from a research perspective and
from a machine learning perspective
we are on top of the state of the art in
the sense that
we are using advanced facilities for
example for
active learning as much as we are in
fact
using feedback provided by tool owners
concerning the metrics themselves
which need uh themselves validation
as well um last but not least from a
verification perspective
you can think of all sorts of
constraints uh from a privacy and
security or
i don't know even design pattern
violations perspective now we
have in fact implemented
a tool for which you can define specific
policies
that you want your data intensive
pipeline based on serverless computing
you want that pipeline to uphold and
support
inside the verification tool this is
possible
i will also show you an example of this
in the next couple of slides uh in the
scope
of the via rota smart tourism
system because this system is in fact
one of the case studies that we have to
conduct
as part of radon now
via rota in fact is a
pretty complex i want to say
recommendation system
for smart tourism so for example
one of the business centers is optimized
personalized tour plans
but you might also have all sorts of
opinions from customers to points of
interest
and you have all sorts of challenges
with respect to that
let's check out one of the models that
we have
in fact realized for this application
this is one of the topologies as you can
see
here you have all sorts of s3 buckets
all of this is tangled upon amazon web
services technology
and it is using uh apache nifi
as a middleware for the data pipeline
which is in fact
an extract transform load pipeline
and as you can see of the left hand side
there is in fact
a public cloud
cloud invoking trigger
because at this stage the application is
interacting with
an open file solution which is stored
indoors to the application owner
at the same time you also have s3
buckets which contain
all sorts of data inputs from the
external environment
uh now inside the red arrows
you can see or rather you cannot see but
if you would click on these red arrows
you would see constraints
being defined on each of these red
arrows
and verified via the
um the constraint definition language
and
the constraints verification tool
uh and uh that
really concludes my talk so
i want to give space for
questions which i presume will take
place
next week the last point i want to
mention is i'm leaving a number of
bibliographic items for you to go crazy
about
uh some of these reflect some of the
concepts that i've talked about
or some of the constructs that i've
defined uh
so if there is anything which is not
clear
just go crazy with some of these
publications i'm sure that
you might be able to to to clarify your
ideas around these
or on the other hand if you have
questions on any of these
uh just please let me
let me know in our q a session uh
next tuesday i want to say or wednesday
yeah whatever next q a session for for
this uh
video and let's take it from here uh
all right so thanks for having me thanks
for
fdr for uh arranging this and thanks to
all you guys the pi data community
uh ciao
you